[Music]
when you hear a strange sound drop to
the ground
a sound
like what
like that
it's officially award season people
which means our long annual debate
surrounding who should win who might
surprise us and who got snubbed is just
getting started and every year the
oscars are bound to have a few upsets
have you ever thought about my
responsibilities oh dave what are you
talking about have you ever had a single
moments thought about my
responsibilities have you ever thought
for a single solitary moment about my
responsibilities to my employers but we
love to champion great films and hope
they get the recognition they deserve
but not all of those great films will go
home with the golden statue so in
anticipation of this year's academy
awards we're counting down classic
movies snubbed during award season
[Music]
number 10 the big lebowski
in a filmography studded with cult
classics the coen brothers the big
lebowski might be the cultist which is
to say that when it arrived in theaters
it landed with nowhere near the impact
you might suspect today in spite of a
top-notch cast as well as a quotable
screenplay lebowski eked out less than
20 million dollars during its theatrical
run and although critics were generally
kind they weren't exactly falling over
themselves to proclaim its everlasting
virtues but the cohens had the last
laugh in the long run oscars are nice
but how many movies have inspired their
own religion starring jeff bridges john
goodman julianne moore and directed by
joel cohen critics say the big lebowski
is typically stunning visuals and sharp
dialogue from the coen brothers brought
to life with strong performances from
goodman and bridges
where's the money lebowski
we want that money lebowski
bonnie says you're good for it
where's the money lebowski
where's the money lebowski
here's the [ __ ] money [ __ ]
oh
it's down there somewhere let me take
another look
with us
your wife owes money to jackie treehorn
that means you owe money a jackie
treehorn
ever thus the dead beats lebowski
oh no don't do this see what happens
lebowski you got the wrong guy i'm the
dude man your name's lebowski lebowski
your wife is bunny
my my
my wife bunny
do you see a wedding ring on my finger
does this place look like i'm married
the toilet seat's up man
is this
obviously you're not a golfer
number nine the shining
like comedy horror hasn't always found
the warmest reception at the academy a
horror movie adapted from a best seller
by stephen king who hasn't always been a
critic starling himself probably never
stood a good chance of receiving oscar's
recognition either on the other hand the
big screen version of kings the shining
boasted a stellar pedigree both on
screen and behind the cameras with jack
nicholson starring opposite shelley
duvall and stanley kubrick directing
this terrifying descent into snow bound
madness could easily have earned a
nomination or three alas it came up
empty forever depriving nicholson the
opportunity to stroll up to the podium
and shout here's oscar starring jack
nicholson shelley duvall danny lloyd and
directed by stanley kubrick critics say
though it deviates from stephen king's
novel stanley kubrick's shining is a
chilling often baroque journey into
madness exemplified by an unforgettable
turn from jack nicholson
little pigs
little pigs
let me come in
[Music]
not by the hair on your chinny chin chin
[Music]
then i'll huff
and i'll puff
and i'll blow your house in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here's johnny
number eight heat
one of a handful of thrillers to make
such stylishly effective use of its los
angeles locations that the city is
virtually a character unto itself
michael mann's heat might be hands down
the sleekiest cops and robbers
suspenseflick of the 90s and this is
really saying something considering man
had to weave a tangled web of plot lines
involving a crowded marquee topping
ensemble not even the combined might of
two of hollywood's greatest espions
could earn this classic heist picture
any attention from the academy man's
next release 1999's the insider made up
for lost opportunities with an
impressive seven nominations none of
which it sadly won starring al pacino
robert de niro val kilmer and directed
by michael mann critics say though al
pacino and robert de niro share but a
handful of screen minutes together he is
an engrossing crime drama that draws
compelling performances from its stars
and confirms michael mann's mastery of
the genre put your hands where i could
see him all right
i tell you what to do i tell you how to
do it
with your right hand only your right
hand only
take the package and throw it in here
[ __ ] behind you on the right
[Music]
number seven bringing up baby the oscars
are traditionally fairly dismissive of
comedies and lists of classic laughers
that deserved a nod from the academy is
long but bringing up baby starring cary
grant as an uptight zoologist and
katherine hepburn as the ditz who turns
his life upside down belongs at or near
the top critics were generally
enthusiastic about grant and hepburn's
second big screen pairing but the
audience's response was decidedly mixed
despite strong receipts in a handful of
locations baby landed with a thud in
many parts of the country and was only
ultimately saved from the cultural
dustbin thanks to a second life granted
by television screenings more than a
decade later starring catherine hepburn
cary grant charlie ruggles and directed
by howard hawks critics say with
catherine hepburn and cary grant at
their effervescent best bringing a baby
is a seamlessly assembled comedy with
enduring appeal now
look here youtube get yours up like a
rabbit cause we've got something to tell
you if you ever want to get out of this
chair you better listen i'm listening
quiet young they didn't want to get to
you later i want you to tell me the
truth the whole truth and nothing about
the truth well what did my aunt say my
quiet dream what did my aunt say you're
right why she said now young lady you
haven't got an answer but i certainly
have got no quiet please now look here
young color i want you to tell me just
exactly what were you doing tonight well
we were hunting for a leopard you were
hunting for a leopard no not now look
here look here already now you know
that's silly there never was a leopard
in the whole state of connecticut well
there is now yeah now young lady isn't
here i'm going to stay here if it takes
all year i am waiting for you to tell
the truth oh if you're going to wait for
her to tell the truth you'll have a long
gray beard down to here you know it's a
funny thing my grandfather quiet young
man listen i don't want any more slick
remarks out of you well this is a jail i
want you to have a little respect for
the law i'm just trying to explain mr
constable you see it it all started over
in maya at her aunt's house her aunt's
house yes yes you see her and promised
to give her hold on hold on there bub
just a minute she hasn't got an answer i
certainly have she's my father's sister
now look here comfortable come over here
stop wasting
oh lady yes i certainly do well now i
gave you my aunt's telephone number
didn't i yep and you called her up
didn't you i sure did and what did she
say well if she said that you were home
in bed then what am i doing here well
you're here because you're you you're
your aunt she could oh confounded lady
you know that you haven't got a man but
if i did have another she'd muzzle you
number six three kings
david o russell's movies have piled up a
number of oscar nominations and wins
over the years and it'd be hard to argue
that he's been unfairly ignored by the
academy still though looking back it's a
little surprising to note that russell's
three kings didn't pick up a single
nomination a critical and commercial hit
this pitch black satire of modern
warfare and global american politics is
a rare message movie that works as pure
entertainment and it found russell
employing a few nifty visual tricks too
any or all of the above might have been
good for awards consideration alas
russell would have to contend himself
with the awards season attention he'd
generate in later years with movies like
the fighter silver linings playbook and
american hustle starring george clooney
mark wahlberg ice cube and directed by
david o russell critics say three kings
successfully blends elements of action
drama and comedy into a thoughtful
exciting movie on the gulf war you all
think america is satan right
america's satan
yes yes yes
look they don't care if they've got
american hair shiite hair sunni hair
they just won't get rid of saddam and
and live life make business
do you want to kill every arab that's
what i was trying to do no
that was not our training we got arab
allies man yeah well we got arabellas
so you don't want to kill every arab
well no he's just had no high school
no high school don't tell people that
that's what'd they say i says you have
terrible haircuts
troy gave me this haircut it's a bad
haircut
number five once upon a time in the west
sergio leones once upon a time in the
west synthesized tropes from the already
well-trod genre and fired them back at
an audience not yet accustomed to seeing
its frontier mythology deconstructed the
film also represented an artistic leap
forward for leone who used a much slower
pace and more realistic tone to tell the
tale of an unsavory hired gun whose
campaign of terror against a railroad
town is complicated by a lone vigilante
with a mysterious vendetta better late
than never west has steadily built a
devoted following since its release and
influenced generations of america's most
popular filmmakers starring henry fonda
claudia cardinale charles bronson and
directed by sergio leone critics say
once upon a time in the west is a
landmark sergio leone spaghetti western
masterpiece featuring a classic moriconi
score
[Music]
frank
frank sent us
did you bring a horse for me
well
looks like we're
looks like we're shy of one horse
you brought two too many
[Music]
[Music]
ah
number four mean streets
martin scorsese's long streak of oscar
futility really got going with 1973's
mean streets which found the young
director determined to make a personal
film after the frustration of working
for hire on roger corman's boxcar bertha
emboldened by disappointment and
professional desperation scorsese drew
on his roots in new york city's little
italy neighborhood to tell the story of
an ambitious but conflicted young
gangster and his fraught relationships
with a young woman and her brother
although mean streets whiffed at the
academy awards it started scorsese on
his way to elite filmmaker status even
if he did end up having to wait until
2007 and threw five nominations to win
his first best director oscar starring
robert de niro harvey keitel amy
robinson and directed by martin scorsese
critics say mean streets is a powerful
tale of urban sin and guilt that marks
scorsese's arrival as an important
cinematic voice and features
electrifying performances from harvey
keitel and robert de niro what are you
coming out going shopping when you own
somebody money johnny that ain't right
what are you doing what you got charlie
i'm going to pay him next week i'm going
to pay you guys you're going to go to
you're going to you don't do nothing how
much you got there i got my own i mean i
got another 40 dollars
i got about 40.
[Music]
what what are you doing now i'm lying
i'm holding onto this until next week
till you make the next payment what are
you talking about what's a little mortal
for you hey it's a mistake
yeah it's a mistake hey listen i swear
to my mother you come with me next
tuesday
i signed the paycheck over to you
charlie i swear to my mother swear to
christ okay come on you come it's a
hundred ten dollars you give it to mike
come on give me some money we got this
two people
we're gonna get laid
[Music]
yeah
come on that's enough for you come on
give me another five come on which one
do you want
mom you make you're leaving me with not
we gotta go eat that's it now you better
make do for this for the week all right
which one do you want which one you want
i want the wine challenge she's nice i
like that one she's the one on the left
nah she knew what not what your left arm
we both stand the same way well i don't
know that don't matter
number three breathless
when jean-luc gadard's breathless
arrived in 1960 there was no way for
critics to know they were witnessing one
of the most influential works in all of
cinema as well as the arrival of one of
the medium's greatest attors but
everyone who saw it including more than
2 million french film goers knew that
they were watching something bold and
new it was also recognized as part of
the emerging french new wave how it came
up empty with the academy is up for
debate but there's no arguing it's
lasting impact among directors as well
as critics breathless is regularly cited
on lists of the all-time greatest films
starring jean-paul belmondo gene seberg
daniel belangi and directed by jean-luc
goddard critics say breathless re-wrote
the rules of cinema and more than 50
years after its arrival jean lucadaard's
paradigm shifting classic remains every
bit as vital
yep
[Music]
never
me
number two king kong a creature feature
so massive that its very title can be
used as a colloquialism for big and
powerful despite being remade several
times over the years the original
remains of the few classic black and
white movies that many modern film goers
have seen a critical and commercial
success kong set a thrilling new
benchmark for special effects
unfortunately the oscars didn't have a
category for that type of achievement
yet but what it lacks in award season
hardware it's clearly more than made up
for in lasting cultural impact starring
fay ray bruce cabot robert armstrong and
directed by marion c cooper and ernest b
shoudsak critics say king kong explores
the soul of a monster making audiences
scream and cry throughout the film in
large part due to kong's breakthrough
special effects
[Music]
[Music]
up
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
and finally number one
m
the way we talk about director fritz
lang today you'd think that he was
swimming in awards during his lifetime
but in reality he racked up an
astonishing zero oscar nominations m
uses sound in a number of inventive ways
including his enormously influential
decision to make greeks in the hall of
the mountain king the recurring theme
music for peter lori's villainous hans
becker it's gone on to be reissued
numerous times continuing all the while
to enjoy near universal critical acclaim
in fact it's one of a small handful of
classic films to boast a 100 tomato
meter rating an unfortunate oversight on
the academy's part but given that lang's
name has become synonymous with
groundbreaking genius among cinema buffs
it's safe to say all's well that ends
well starring peter laurie ellen widman
ingay landgut and directed by fritz lang
critics say m is a landmark
psychological thriller with arresting
images deep thoughts on modern society
and peter lori in his finest performance
hey
[Music]
[Music]
um
foreign
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love
until next time i am your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
you